[Music]
ah
are you okay to do the uh the call now
yeah
you've actually
i actually thought it was at one o'clock
today but uh so i'm actually at an
airport doing uh at an air show
um but i'm good i can do it i'm just
sitting in an airplane wow
okay then i've never interviewed someone
while they're sitting
in an airplane in an airplane i've never
done an interview in an airplane so this
is the first we're supposed to
okay
uh
you got to forgive you got to forgive
all the the airplane noises in the
background
this really looks the part here kevin
i've got to say
you are looking like indiana jones over
here me um okay this is cool
so this is uh welcome back to the true
jordi podcast ladies and gentlemen i'm
joined today by
a man known as the lion whisperer a man
who i have been
tracking down for a good five years for
an interview now i finally made it
happen
i've been a big fan of kevin
richardson's work for a long time so
thanks for coming on kevin it's a
pleasure thanks for having me on yeah i
guess uh just to um give our our
audience a bit of an idea of of who you
are and what you do you've devoted your
life to animals um how many animals
do you have and sort of what kind of
facility do you have yeah i ran a
sanctuary basically just north of
pretoria it's home to 23
lions
um eleven spotted are you know one
strapped and four leopards
um so it's basically just a safe haven
to give these animals a
quality of life and uh
you know a dignified life
until
the day they pass away you know so
that's the mission once they pass away
they won't be replaced um we have a no
breeding policy at the sanctuary so
there's no newcomers
and we don't operate a rescue facility
so i'm not a rescue facility so once
these
animals pass then that'll be that and we
will morph into
something different which is most likely
a rehabilitation center for
wild animals and the
the premises is that if they come to the
facility they must go
um so that's that's the idea and what
made you want to set this up in the
first place yeah i got involved with
lions um
around about 1998 and i went to a
facility that uh
offered lines for the the public to come
and view and and to interact with and
and all of the above and i i saw nothing
wrong with it at the time i was a 23
year old
young man
and as i started to um you know work
there started to realize that there were
a few things
that not not a few actually many things
that just went against the grain of
somebody who
liked animals you know the reason i went
to work there was because i enjoyed
animals and
a lot of these facilities i realized
they weren't
what they say they are
and
it's this whole deception
um gig and and uh you know lying to the
public basically and so
i kind of made it my mission to
rescue these animals that i was caring
for
um i couldn't take all of them um and
and so i took the the ones that i could
get my hands on and
yeah it wasn't an easy uh process of of
the whole transition it wasn't just like
a light switch that you can you know
just switch on or off it was a whole
process to actually
move away from this facility and set up
my own establishment that must have
taken a lot of cash and a lot of a lot
of hard work how did you manage to pull
that together that's not easy yeah
exactly
you know i think what people don't
realize is is the hard work behind
trying to fulfill a vision and uh also
the fact that
you know it i i'd contrary to what a lot
of people would have believed is that i
i wasn't born with a silver spoon in my
mouth and so i had to really figure out
how to make this happen and so just with
a lot of perseverance a lot of
persistence
you know a lot of um you know dodging
and diving to try and uh make sure that
i could actually
wrangle these animals away and do do
what i
wanted to eventually do and achieve and
and then be in control over
my own destiny as well as the animals
you know because
i think the
the thing that i always tell people is
that i'm merely a cust
a custodian of these animals i don't own
them you know i might have legal
guardianship of them but the individuals
each each and every one of them so um
that's merely what i do i'm giving them
a life and
and hopefully whilst doing that um i'm
able to
captivate an audience uh educate an
audience
you know and just make people fall in
love with wildlife so that
um our future generations can have have
these animals around to enjoy too yeah
it seems like your approach is so
different to
what we have all recently been exposed
to in the mainstream media of these uh
tiger documentaries the tiger king
documentary etc um
when we watch those guys with animals
they they operate out of fear
and they've you know the the the animals
clearly recognize weapons and and other
things uh whenever they're pulled out
and whereas with you
you
look like you're one of them and that's
kind of where your reputation and um
where i discovered you was
you know someone who was clearly
accepted
by the animals and that is is shocking
when you first see it for a normal guy
you're like wow this is he's just
like the jungle book like come to life
here you know it's uh it and and they
love you they clearly absolutely love
you these animals um so how did how did
you manage to get that level of
relationship with them it's true what
you say i mean and it's unfortunate
because a lot of people would like to
tie me with the same brush
and uh if you work with uh wild animals
kind of everyone just lumps you into
that tiger king kind of category it's
pretty sad
um i frustrate you kevin sorry to
interrupt you but does that hurt your
feelings given that you're so different
to these guys
i'm thick-skinned hey so yeah in the
past i used to kind of fight it and say
like but why can't they see the
difference
and then i eventually realized that you
know eventually um the cream will rise
to the top you know so you gotta you
gotta just persist and persevere with
your
with your ideals and um
and and so i've done that i've just been
true to myself i've hopefully been true
to myself and
continued to to to um you know not
deviate from from who i am
and what i believe in because there are
people that believe that you know humans
shouldn't interact with wild animals and
you know i i disagree obviously because
i interact with my lines and i feel that
they they have a quality of life because
of it
and without that interaction they would
merely be um animals in cages which is
unfortunate because
you know from where i said now is it a
case of the horses bolted a little bit
like to try and say we shouldn't
interfere with animals it's like well
unfortunately
too many fools out there have already
done that so we unfortunately need
people like yourself to try and
uh keep a hold of of these animals and
look after them well yeah i mean that is
exactly my mandate for for the animals
in my care but i don't advocate that we
need to
everyone needs to go out and become a
lion whisperer because i think it's a
you know it's a
it's a hard grind it's a it's a
commitment it takes a lot of money
it takes a you know
it takes a lot out of you and and uh i
would prefer to see these animals in the
wild as you quite correctly say
uh we have done this to them they didn't
ask to be put in captivity and people
continually will continue to breed these
these animals for captivity and that's
the unfortunate thing and i think until
such time as uh legislation changes and
and and it's outlawed
and there's always going to be somebody
breeding and there's always going to be
somebody rescuing you know and so for me
i drew the line in the sand and said we
are not a rescue center and i don't want
to be
a place that just takes in all these
rescues from all around the world
because then we part of this vicious
cycle and i don't want to be part of a
vicious cycle i want to be part of
helping
rehabilitate animals that can go back to
the wild
because i think that that is
conservation and that is that is purpose
um that is purposeful but you know it's
not to say
that the animals in my care can't have a
or hold a conservation value and i think
that's uh that's key because a lot of
people out there say oh well there's no
conservation value in captive animals
and i disagree because i think
captive animals if utilized correctly
can have a conservation value and that
could be just from an educational
perspective
and educating people not
as to you know the attributes of the
animal educating people as to why this
animal shouldn't be in a cage
and then also just raising awareness and
hopefully money funding to
contribute to to wild species
conservation i mean yeah you've
definitely done that obviously and it it
makes absolute sense to me i think
anyone who
is
going to disagree with you is just
trying to cause problems at that point
because the amount of views that you've
generated on youtube and the awareness
that you've raised is it you can't argue
with the numbers they're there in black
and white
and um and the thing that obviously
grabs everyone is is seeing you eye to
eye
with these animals and i think it's a
basic question but it's
what does it feel like to be
that close to
a killing machine you know it's
dangerous
it's dangerous when you don't know what
you're doing and then it's like anything
you know i'm sitting talking to you in
an airplane but an airplane can be one
of the most dangerous things you can you
know um enter into if you don't know
what you're doing um but if you do know
what you're doing an airplane becomes uh
relatively safe there's always risk
i will say that and and nothing with
nothing worthwhile in life is without
risk
um but what does it feel like well i've
never you know it's hard to explain
because how do you explain that to
somebody
um but you know it i never take it for
granted every time i'm with these
animals and in fact you'll you'll know
phil who set up this interview
for the first time
in his life he's come to the sanctuary
and he's able he was able to see me with
the with the lions and he said to me
kevin it's it's unbelievable because you
watch the videos and it's and it's
awesome to see on the videos don't get
me wrong but to see you in real life
it's so much more visceral it's so much
more more real
and
he he further went on to say that it was
like he had this adrenaline rush just
watching me with the line because every
bone in his body says you shouldn't be
doing that
and then
so but then he understands that you know
these lines are are you know my friends
in the sense that i'm part of their
groups prior to their frauds and
you know so that's really what it's
about it's about getting to know them
very intimately knowing what they like
and knowing what they don't like and
then making sure you don't do what they
don't like yeah it's very clear that you
know they're you you know their moods
and you have a you communicate with them
and um have you
all right so he said he felt an
adrenaline rush do you have an any
element of fear left after all these
years or is it just complete calm yeah
so it's i suppose that an elegy is like
asking a motogp or formula one driver if
they still get adrenaline
um on the start line you know when
they're starting for a race and i think
that always is there
i think you just get used to it and you
because it becomes the norm it's a it's
a normal a new normal and i think it's
the same thing you know when i i don't
get an adrenaline that rush when i go in
with the lions because you know there's
this com
this this comfortableness
about
the the friendship you know the
relationship so but there are times when
you know they do things and then you you
kind of go like
as if i needed reminding but yeah they
they lions
yeah they're very powerful and and very
um
they're very very powerful very strong
but yet so gentle and what what always
impresses me
is not the strength of a lion but the
gentleness of a lion
yeah when we see you sort of rolling
around with them and cuddling them i
mean it looks like the most fun thing in
the world
but
yeah all it takes i guess is one little
mood change one little nibble
and that can can snap you out of it what
what would be the um have you have you
got a memory of the more sort of uh
frightened you've been around one of
these things like yeah look i mean just
just to to um
pick up on what what you just said is is
no
they not you know even when you do get
um an injury it's it's normally not
malicious so they're not out there to
once they are a part of a group they're
not there to injure each other so like
they would not intentionally injure each
other
um they they don't ever intentionally
injure you so you may very well get a
stretch or uh inadvertently be bitten
because you know they miss mistook what
you did for
a threat or but it's never uh malicious
and and normally it's controlled so
actually in 20
25 years almost now of working i mean
there has been a few incidents but very
very few and they have mostly been as a
result of my
my my stupidity like for example way
back in the days when a lioness had her
had cubs and and she mistook me for
hurting her cubs then then she would you
know she would lash out at any pride
member for
for trying trying their luck with her
cubs you know so
you you live and learn about
and even in a situation like that you
know she gives you a lot of warnings um
so yeah it's it is an interesting
phenomenon a lot of people just think
that these predators are all or nothing
it's almost like that
they think they've got this shark
mentality which even sharks don't have
you know um so lions is a lot more going
on inside the head than most people
would uh you know like to imagine
i mean you've you've obviously mentioned
um
moto jp and a formula one and there you
are sat in an airplane and a guy who
hangs out with lions naturally we're
probably all thinking this guy's a bit
of an adrenaline junkie here
is is that true or
well i think adrenaline junkies don't
think they're adrenaline junkies they
think it's normal
so
for me i just don't understand why
people don't want to do these things
yeah because life is too short to exist
you know and yes god forbid uh pass away
untimely
i would i wouldn't change a thing
because i've lived a good life you know
so life is for living
and if it's cut short because of
something that i've i've partaken in
then so be it i would rather have lived
that kind of existence than you know
just existing day-to-day
safe you know worrying about everything
worrying about being safe
it's not my character
can you um can can we go through some of
the animals you you actually look after
in terms of their breeds and uh maybe
maybe talk a little bit about
some unexpected qualities like because
we
i think the general public just have
this disney stereotype in their head for
example
hyenas are all evil because yeah of the
lion king you know um
so so you know let's start with hyenas
for example i know you you you have a
good relationship with them and um
what are they like
i adore hyenas and i i adore them for
the very reason that they are underdogs
and that they've been painted in such a
bad light by
you know
documentaries of yesteryear
which have been endorsed by some really
powerful organizations which is quite
sad because
it's just sensationalism
and disney didn't do hyenas any justice
either or any they did them a huge
disservice hyenas are super intelligent
animals once you get to know them or
have spent enough time in the bush just
to
observe them super intelligent and i'm
talking about on a level with
chimpanzees
you know in some in some experiments
that have been done on hyena they've
outperformed chimpanzees in
collaborative problem-solving
experiments
so you're not talking about a a stupid
animal here you're talking about a
highly intelligent animal and actually
when you look at a hyena face to face
they're actually extremely good looking
and this is probably people are going to
go yeah that's your opinion they are
extremely good looking they
are wonderful but but
and this is the big butt is that they
are very hierarchical so they have
strict hierarchies and they they respect
those hierarchies and they're always
trying to uh challenge you know they're
always trying to get up
you know on the in the corporate
environment they're always trying to
climb that corporate ladder no different
to humans you know i know some nasty
nasty humans who have done some really
horrible things to get ahead in the
world you know so we look at that and we
say oh well that's just business oh
that's just been a tough business man
but aina has dirt in the wild and then
they are
are thought to be horrible um so no they
they're intelligent um they're very
caring their mothers are
super super protective and nurturing and
brilliant mothers really really
brilliant
and just a wonderful animal and i you
know all the videos i make on arenas a
lot of the people come back the
commentary generally about the hyenas is
um kevin i had no idea that they were
just so awesome and so you know people
have fallen in love with hyenas due to
my my videos and you know
for those naysayers out there not one
person has come back saying oh i want to
get to peta you know they're going we
understand the complexities of hua we
shouldn't get a hyena because hyenas
should be in clans they shouldn't be
kept as individuals
you know so
and i understand that hyenas need
large tracts of land large amounts of
space and they need these social
hierarchies to to thrive so you know
that's just an example of hyenas and
lions of also lions have also been you
know i think uh stereotyped in so many
ways because we just say oh it's the
king of the jungle they're ferocious
they just you know throw their weight
around and get
and get what they want because they're
so powerful and it's not like that at
all i i think lions can be very much a
scary cat
and scary cats and then they um can be
freaked out quite easily and subdued
quite easily and that's hence why we can
see why people
can beat them into submission you know
you see them in circuses and you see
them in the movies like the tiger king
and yeah these these animals
are not understanding where they fit in
and they they can be fearful and this
big powerful animal can be beaten into
submission and become it can just become
a cardboard cutout of what it's really
meant to be so you know and then just
the personalities brian i mean it's just
unbelievable from what you know 23 lines
23 different personalities like like i'm
a personality a newer personality and
everyone around us is it's exactly the
same with these lions so for us to look
at them and say that this is how the
species is
this is very uh oversimplified you know
they they extremely complicated and and
take that take personalities into
account you know you also have uh cheat
hours and and uh leopards i believe or
is it panthers as well yeah so we're
rehabilitating um eight
cheetah for rewilding and we we're about
to actually we're about a month uh just
six weeks away
from releasing these eight cheetah back
into the wild so we took on these eights
cheetah they actually called the miracle
eight and they were they were rescued as
cubs from the wild because five of
them's mother was poached which is a
huge um problem in in
in africa in the world poaching you know
poaching for meat poaching for body
parts etc and their mother was
inadvertently caught
in a in a snail and uh when the purchase
found her they they basically skinned
her and chopped chopped up her body for
for the for the trade for the muji trade
and for the parts trade and so the guard
uh found these five cubs and and we were
contacted as a as a result and then
later on three more cubs were found
after their mother had had come together
with a lion and the lion had killed her
um so we put these five these five with
these three and we've rehabilitated them
over the last year and a half and
they're now almost two and we're going
to be releasing them into the wild which
is a huge um you know milestone for us
and for them it's it's just such a
wonderful
project of being a part of and that's so
that's the cheetah and then i've got
here i've got four four leopard that are
actually melanistic so they're black
leopards that i look after they in my
care
and uh yeah they they obviously can't be
released into the wild they're old now
you know two of them are 20 years old so
it's very old um you know they they end
of end of life kind of age and the other
two are about 12. so they've got about
you know eight eight years or so when we
look at all of these animals i think
obviously from a human perspective we
look at how physically capable they all
are is there a one that stands out among
them where you think you know what maybe
that is the surprise package
athletically like no one would realize
the strength or the speed or something
like that yeah look i think people
underestimate leopards we all see we all
know the lion is the king of the jungle
um you know he's big he's powerful he's
strong
but we look at leopards and we saw they
just they they you know
a quarter the size of a lion in some
cases
and uh we underestimate them that's one
of the most powerful
animals i i can you know i've ever come
across they are persistent they
tenacious uh when the leopard sees
something and wants it he goes for it
and any animal that can carry an impala
which weighs about 60 kilograms up a
tree in its jaws any animal that can do
that i have huge respect for and
leopards do that they carry animals um
as much as their own body weight um you
know up a tree it's insane so yeah
leopards you know always knew that they
were impressive but
working around leopards and despite
their size you know dynamite really does
come in small packages in the case of
leopards
yeah um you mentioned earlier about the
the fact that animals are being
these wild animals are now turning up in
america and places like that
um what do you what do you think is
causing this boom where you've now we're
now looking at a situation where we
might have more animals
more wild animals in captivity in
america than actually in the world in
the future yeah look i don't think
that's a
all of a sudden a boom i think it's
always been there and i think what's
just made it made people more aware is
social media so because we are are able
to communicate so much quicker these
days
um
many more people are aware of what's
going on all around the world so
you know this breeding of of um the
exotic wild pet trade uh in america has
been going on for for decades and um
it's a you know it's a case of people
wanting
that pet that their mate doesn't have
you know your mate's got a poor bulldog
and a football and this and that oh i've
got a tiger you know i've got a tiger
beat that you know yeah um and i suppose
what what
you know
what is
half the problem is the fact that the
authorities in the united states allow
it um you shouldn't be allowed to keep a
big cat unless you
can show
that you have um you know reason to to
keep it um and that you
are you've had the correct training and
that you know what you're doing it's
almost like letting um a kid jumping
into an airplane and go fly
just because just because he's had some
practice on flight simulator yeah at
home on his computer it's two different
ball games there and this is what what's
been allowed which which is absolutely
perplexing um and it's not just in
america it's the world through arts i
think you know if authorities can clamp
down on that and and and not you know
regulate it to the extent that people
can't just keep these animals and that
it's made illegal
and then we will have to have this
phasing out period and otherwise there's
going to be mass
euthanasia and and then we're going to
have animal
rights groups and activists up in arms
um so
you know whichever way you look at it
they they're unhappy because animals are
being kept in these you know horrid
conditions um but they would also be
happy if there was a
an issuance you know from government
saying listen we need to
stop this in its tracks because even if
all these animals in america were
rescued where are they going to go
you know i'm a sanctuary you've got 23
lines and let me tell you it's an
expensive pastime keeping these animals
in tip-top shape as they get older
their veterinary intervention and care
is so much greater and it costs so much
money and then when i hear of facilities
saying well we have 400 rescued lions
i'm going well you cannot possibly look
after 400 rescued lines properly unless
you've got gazillions of dollars just
flowing in and we know that this is not
the case and the other problem with
these these rescue facilities is that as
soon as people stop donating
and the next best thing comes along
the money dries up they've still got
this expense so what do you do about
that and a lot of these animals then
land up suffering so you know as as
harsh as um sometimes euthanizing
animals is sometimes um
it's arguably the more humane thing to
do
for these animals otherwise they'll end
up living lives
in cages um pacing up and down
and it's just so that a few people can
feel happy about themselves you know
this is a lot of the time what
frustrates me about rescuing is that
at the rescue
rescuing is not about getting an animal
and making it safe rescuing was about
starting that process and then
completing it in other words you know
facilitating the the the good care of
that animal until the day it passes away
in captivity and that can be 20 years 25
years you know and who is committing for
that period of time none of these people
who commit to rescuing commit to those
animals for that period of time and
that's why it's flawed well you've
really helped me understand better the
whole process and and how things can be
misrepresented in the public eye for
people's own benefits obviously
the tiger king documentary was the huge
i mean it was literally everything that
anyone was talking about did you watch
that unfortunately i had the displeasure
of watching it yes yeah and how did
it was pure entertainment and i think
obviously a lot of us are able to just
not understand what they're doing to the
animals therefore we're probably not
feeling the way you are how did you feel
watching all of that well look i mean it
yeah i'm mildly amusing because these
people you actually look at that think i
actually cannot believe people would
behave like this but then very upsetting
in the sense that these animals are
being treated the way they are being
treated and i mean all elements of the
tiger king i must be honest i mean it
was every single component was just jaw
dropping it was you know from
you know
from every every um
aspect you in every angle you looked at
that program i mean there was just it
begged belief actually so yeah it was um
all the more reason
to
um revisit why
animals like uh tigers and lions etc
shouldn't be kept as pets or or in many
cases in captive situations i think uh
you know often as i've said many times
often the rescue facility can be as bad
as the facility that they were rescued
from
um and that you know just because
somebody says i'm a rescue facility it
doesn't mean that they're good
so we must be very careful of that and
unfortunately
yeah it's a it's it did open the eyes so
i think that was a good thing but i hope
you know 2020 we were all locked down
everyone was
sitting at home uh with nothing better
to do so this was an entertaining
program to watch talked about it for the
next
three four months the celebrities and
you know um everyone was was was
chatting about target king but you know
two years down the line
what's been done
um it's gone quiet
and everyone just remembers the um the
memes from the targeting what's happened
to the animals
you are spot on you that you couldn't
have put it better everyone remembers
the memes but what about the animals you
know and yeah when watching that um just
uh just to cap off the tiger king thing
uh obviously he is viewed as the bad guy
he is viewed as the one with a bad
facility etc etc and carol baskin is
made out to be the sort of good guy and
the person with the good facility but
obviously
i don't know what i'm looking at you you
know what you're looking at how did you
view carol baskin out of interest yeah
look i mean has a reputation and
i don't know personally and i don't know
anyone who featured on that program
personally but um you know
from my perspective somebody who works
hands-on with the animals the way the
animals are are kept it's just
not conducive to a great life if i was a
lion trust me knowing lions for 25 years
and knowing what they
um would enjoy enjoy not being
not living in the wild which they not
there's so much more that you need to do
to keep these animals um you know
stimulated
and
and not just mentally but physically you
know so
these animals need physical exercise
that's the way they were designed they
need mental stimulation that's the way
they were designed they were designed to
you know go after things and and and and
you know
catch things and
that's if you think about what they do
in the in the wild so yeah i don't think
any and and i'm i'm pointing a finger
directly back at myself because
um i've realized that rescuing uh
lions tigers etc perpetually is not the
answer i've rare and that's why i say to
you once the animals in marquette
live a decent life because of the
interactions without the interactions
their life is questionable it's a it's
just a line in a cage you know so the
fact that they can actually get up and
go out and swap enclosures and have a
bit of a quality of life it's i always
say it's like almost like having a dog
that lives its entire life in the
courtyard
and all you do is throw it a bone every
now and again or a box or something and
say hey look i gave it you know i gave
it some enrichment and some stimulation
no that dog wants to go out and wants to
go walking and you know and and that's
the same as my lines and my care it
gives them a um
something to look forward to in life you
know what i'm saying can you uh educate
us on
ligers because i didn't really even know
they existed until that documentary i
basically was shocked that they could
cross-breed like that is that is that
ethical or well it's not ethical i will
say that off the bat i mean ligers
is just a deliberate crossing of tigers
and lions and uh then you get tigons
which is depending on if you breed the
male and the female or the female in the
male
um it's uh
it's going to depend whether you get a
liger or a tiger but this is just the um
this warped human
mind that we want to have something
bigger and better and you know grander
than the next person and it's just this
ego thing why you would ever consider it
i have no idea and and yet you know
people are allowed to do it and they get
away with doing it
um so no i don't i'm not a
fan of cross-breeding i don't see the
purpose and the point what what is the
purpose of the point i mean you're not
going to be releasing ligers into the
wild and so for me
it's about conservation and it's not
about species it's about species
preservation not individual preservation
if you look at conservation as a whole
the whole idea of conservation is to see
a species thrive so for example
conservation of lions means that we want
to see lion numbers go up in the wild
throughout where they occur and to
repopulate areas where they once
occurred
so where are we going to put a liga
besides in a cage
for people's entertainment it makes no
sense obviously you've had to make quite
a lot of sacrifices in your personal
life i would assume how's that been
because
these animals do take up a lot of your
time yeah look personal sacrifices is is
become a norm
so i don't see it as that anymore
because these these animals are my
family so you know do you
when you're when your children are
growing up you make a lot of personal
sacrifices too to make sure that they
you know well educated that um you know
you attend their their sports functions
etc they take up a lot of time but we
don't begrudge that because they are
children you know so
although i've made a lot of sacrifices
for for the cats um
i would do it over again in a heartbeat
for those animals but i wouldn't
want to perpetuate it's like once you've
had kids of your own and then somebody
says your kids are now 18 you want some
more i'm like no thanks
paid my shoes
yeah i hear you and
obviously like
for people at home
we're sort of thinking i wonder if if
the love of a lion is kind of like the
love of a dog or is it more human-like
to you no it's it's you know i know some
people who love their dogs more than
humans so
it just depends on on you as a as an
individual but i would say like my dog
that lives in our house with my family
is part of the family yeah i have my two
kids and we have a dog and we have
basically three kids um and so
so my dog is part of my family and
that's so
so true are the the lines in the
sanctuary you know we know them
individualistically they've all got you
know we know their names we know
we know everything about them everything
they used to know you know they're not
just a number
um
so you know when i talk about them
it's affectionately
siam or it's affectionately meg or
bobcat or whatever and i can every time
i mention that that name
all these images are conjured up in my
mind of bobcat or meg or siam or whoever
you know the animal is and so when we
lose them we are devastated but by the
same token
we are
we are pleased in the sense that and at
least this is from my perspective is
that i i was able to
um you know fulfill uh my commitment to
them and give them a a quality of life
the best i could at least um in in a
captive situation um so that's yeah they
like family
is that some sort of spiritual quest for
you in terms of like what you feel like
the meaning of your life is i'm not
really uh brian you are i mean it's it
just was it's a weird thing it's it's
it's like you you commit to something
and then i've always had that
that kind of way about me um
once
maybe it takes me a little bit longer
than others to get excited about
something but once i get excited about
something and my passion bubbles through
for something i'm i'm a stickler for
keeping on at it so you know i always
say
passion
uh perseverance and then a very
important part of that comes commitment
and i find these days commitment is is
lacking
you know and perseverance people all
come to me and they say i've got the
passion i want to
you know open a rehab rescue whatever
facility and i go well do you have the
commitment um because
you know it's not always happy homes and
gardens and
you know if you're starting with a young
animal
they grow up very quickly and then you
stuck with this big animal and how how
are you going to look after this animal
for 20 years 25 years have you thought
that through and whichever whatever you
do
um to look after them you're going to
get criticized so you know you'll you're
going to because there's always somebody
out there who thinks they could do it
better than you um until they actually
they're trying to do it themselves and
they realize it's not as
easy as as it seems as i always say to
people i i'm no one special it's just
i've
made a commitment and i'm i'm
you know i'll i'll do everything in my
power to honor that commitment until
those animals have at least passed on
when you say you're no one special i
think um you obviously are a special guy
but i appreciate where you're coming
from and that uh
you haven't got the ego that we see on a
lot of these people who want to surround
themselves with these animals
um
you know you're quite low-key even to
get an interview with you took me about
five years so
i find that hard to believe
you didn't try hard enough i've been
emailing it
but um
but yes ma'am you didn't persevere you
didn't persevere commitment
[Laughter]
when it comes to animal lovers you know
i i consider myself a huge animal lover
and i i guess i feel like um i even
gravitate more towards being around
animals than people a lot of the time
because you know what you're getting and
um i wondered if you were a little bit
the same in regards to being
uh not necessarily a people person as
much do you find
animal relationships easier than human
ones at this stage well certainly when i
was younger i used to
utter it all the time i hate people i
love animals you know that's when i was
younger but then i realized when i got
older that in order to save animals we
need to have people because without
people buying in
um we're not going to have animals and
then i started to soften towards people
and i realized that
this is generally out there um good
people generally around the world i meet
good people wherever i go
and then there's like two percent maybe
three maybe even five percent i don't
know what the percentage is who cares
that are just plain and simply evil
they're horrible people and you wouldn't
want to
um spend any amount of time with them
you know at all um but by and large most
people are are good and they want to do
good they're just misguided so you know
i figured that my job is to try and
um win people and guide them and and and
utilize my experience um to win them
over and hopefully
you know you you touch somebody who has
the means and mechanisms to help a
conservation organization you know and
that that would be a wonderful thing if
somebody who watched a video of mine
then committed to helping a conservation
organization and that furthermore helped
the species that would be wonderful so
yeah from a youngster who
wasn't really enamored with people to a
adult who
actually sees the good in people
i think that's lovely uh that you that
you've gone that way obviously um
you said you've got a family um and kids
what is what is their situation with the
animals do you allow them to have as
much of a relationship with them as you
have or is it is there a line there
there's definitely a line uh because my
kids
were born after um most of the animals
were adults
and uh and and so
an adult lion or or hyena or leopard has
no
wish to um form a new relationship with
another human being
especially a kid um there's just
something in these animals that is that
kids trigger
triggers their instincts and they
they can't help it and so kids are not
um safe
around around them so
and i could see the frustration whenever
i brought my kids to the sanctuary to
have a look i could see the frustration
in the animals
faces and in their demeanor and i i've
you know i said to to my wife why do we
want to put the kids through that and
why do we want to put the animals
through that because you irritating the
animals and you're making kids that are
going to be scared of of lions
that's not what i want i want my kids to
grow up
loving and revering lines and wanting to
protect and help lines but also
understanding that captivity is not
where we want to focus our attentions
you know so i didn't want to develop
raise kids fearful of these animals and
and they have lions that are frustrated
i want my kids to grow up uh wanting to
see animals in the wild and i'm assuming
that
it seems like the uh from the way you're
describing lions or uh animal any of
those animals they sort of smell
vulnerability it sort of triggers their
sort of hunting instincts i would assume
and then it's so much more than that
right it's just it's not just you know
the they use all their senses like we do
so immediately when there's five people
they'll always look at the smaller one
but they but but then it's not only a
size thing you know because you can have
a very um short adult
but they'll immediately target the kid
so it's a
it's a it's a you know it's a look it's
a sense of smell it's all of the senses
they they're utilizing to
to um
assess who's the weakest kind of link
there and it's not even um you know
sometimes
i look at it and i go is it a prey thing
you know are these lions looking to
you know
eat people it's not about that even in
some aspects it's it's just they they
triggered to go after vulnerability it's
it's not a pray thing it's just like
you know let's just eliminate uh kind of
thing
it's a weird phenomenon it's not food
they're not looking at it as oh there's
a meal it's not like okay well you know
i need to go after the weakest the sick
the lame the weak like they would if
they were hunting
it's just they they programmed to kind
of go after after the kids it's yeah
that makes perfect sense that we've
described that and
uh when i when i was actually reading up
on your story
uh i hope you don't mind me bringing
this up anyway that uh i've seen that
your father had passed when you were
younger and yeah and i i couldn't no but
wonder like looking at the man you've
become and having been through something
like that
uh how that sort of shaped you and also
how you think he would
uh view your life's work now yeah look i
mean yeah my father's passing was
obviously
to a youngster
it's quite a
a blow
but but in a sense it was also a
a reason for
why i went and did what i started doing
when i was young you know i went went
off the rails a bit and needed to be
brought back on them it was almost like
an excuse to rebel
um but
you know it definitely growing up
without a father figure
um and i i i it's no secret i mean i
said it in my book i mean my dad and i
it wasn't the greatest of father-son
relationship so my father figure wasn't
great to begin with
um and so yeah it did shape who i am
because i think you know as a father i
wanted to be um better to my my children
but um also being a
you know always one that was had to be
in control over my own destiny
and it did it did grow me up quicker
than most you know
um so yeah yeah i did have to grow up
quickly as a youngster which which i
don't i don't regret it it's all good
yeah i i hear that man
i lost a parent when i was younger so i
i empathize with that and um i've seen
that um also
um and it's fine if you don't want to
talk about this but i i in the wikipedia
i've seen that there was a an accident
that sort of happened a few years back
where someone lost their life uh with
one of your animals is that correct yeah
look it's something obviously that it's
hard to talk about um
but it is something that happened and
unfortunately you know
accidents can happen
and and they do happen and um you know
there was no ill intention on anyone's
side and
um unfortunately yeah it
accident happened and we've we all have
to live with it and
yeah
do you cope
because
obviously i'm sure you take so much
responsibility in um
like trying to protect everyone as best
you can but like you say these animals
are programmed to do what they do
um
how did you cope with that mentally
afterwards yeah look
ptsd is a real thing
and uh
you know one one has to just uh
everyone has different coping mechanisms
and and i suppose there's no
there's no silver bullet um for uh kind
of recovery and i think uh the
you know time is a healer
and
and that's that's that's that you know
time you you've got to
um just respect that about about people
uh and life life is hard uh life throws
you you think you've got your whole life
sorted
and then there's these
curve balls that get thrown at you you
know so
yeah uh it's it's um you you
time time is what what it takes to
kind of recover and it's all and still
time goes on it's not you never fully
recovered yeah i i hear that and uh
thank you for answering that i'm sure
it's uh not easy to talk about um
a couple of final questions for you mate
i've thoroughly enjoyed this one one
last one is uh how would you like people
to remember you
um
yeah look i think that's a good question
the uh
probably a legacy of somebody who
um helped clients and helped animals you
know so
you know i wouldn't want to be
remembered as oh he was the clown that
um rolled around with lions you know it
would be it would be better to be
remembered as somebody who actually had
a positive influence or positive
kind of effect on on on how people
perceived lions and and um and and
positive on online populations as a
whole conservation you know
it's kind of always look at steve owen i
mean we we all
we all know of steve irwin um and and uh
you know what what did he want his
legacy to be and some people to this day
just still see him as the
the lunatic who used to you know jump on
crocodiles but people are like myself
who understood his value and his worth
understood that it was so much more than
that and that he changed
so many people's mindsets to how they
looked at crocodiles and and reptiles
and snakes you know
snakes included obviously in reptiles so
that's quite a legacy
and so if i could take a leaf out of
that book i'd be quite proud you know i
think you've uh you've certainly nailed
that mate uh final question if i'm ever
in the area can i come and film you
and spend some time there for sure we're
you most welcome
and uh i don't know when next you'll
find yourself in south africa
but uh yeah if you do please do look us
look me up i would absolutely love that
like i'd love to film and uh some some
of your work and uh
i'm i'm like i'm a huge animal lover
especially your animals i think they're
beautiful and uh i love what you do and
i really appreciate you coming on the
podcast mate you're a true gentleman and
uh hopefully we can uh catch up again
sometime awesome and i really appreciate
it thanks for the opportunity and uh
yeah um for the best all right for
everyone who wants to watch kevin
richardson's great work don't forget to
check out the lion whisperer youtube
channel thanks for watching hit that
like button subscribe and we'll see you
later